geographic is really a concerted
scientific effort to make sense of what
is in many ways a deceptively simple
basic human question where do we all
come from you know I think everybody
asks themselves at some point you know
how did we get here why there's so many
different types of people languages
spoken around the world why do we look
so different and so on and we're using
the tools of science and particularly
the tools of molecular genetics to
answer that question to tell the story
of our species in effect how we started
off as a small group of hunter-gatherers
in Africa sixty to seventy thousand
years ago and how within the last 60
thousand years we've scattered to the
wind to populate the world and in the
process increase to six and a half
billion people
well it depends on how far back you want
to go i mean when i was a kid i was
fascinated by history I saw the king tut
exhibit the tour the states back in the
late 70s and you know came away from
that just totally obsessed with the past
and the idea that maybe I could travel
back in time and imagine myself of it
the time of King taught 3,500 years ago
and read everything I could on ancient
history and the Middle Ages and all
sorts of other things and was convinced
that that was the direction I was headed
in and around the time I was nine or ten
my mother and went back to school to get
her PhD in biology and as you do
sometimes you know your kids go into the
into work with her parents i went to the
lab with her and i discovered that
science is really kind of cool it's
really fun you know it's about solving
puzzles on a daily basis and what kid
wouldn't like that and so I decided that
I you know I was interested in science
but I didn't want to give up history
either and I wanted to combine the two
so use science as a tool to study the
past and that led me to study genetics
in college which is kind of the
historical branch of biology if you will
we get our DNA from our parents they got
it from their parents and so it traces
this lineage back in time and it studied
population genetics which is the study
of genetic variation in natural
populations for my PhD and by the time I
was finishing up my PhD was convinced
that this was going to be you know the
main tool for studying human origins and
how we populated the world and went out
to Stanford and did a postdoc there and
ran a research group at Oxford and
followed a typical academic path and
then ended up making a film the journey
of man which aired on PBS in 2003 and
off the the back of that film which was
a co-production with the National
Geographic Channel I started talking to
National Geographic not the media people
but the missions people the people who
funded over 8,000 research grants who
funded the leaky family Thunder Jane
Goodall all these people over the years
about the work we were doing the
scientific work and they literally asked
me this open-ended question if you could
do anything next what would it be and I
said we need more samples we need to
sample the world's DNA we need to
increase our sample size by at least an
order of magnitude study hundreds of
thousands of people around the world in
an effort to figure out how we populate
planet
that was the the Genesis the Genographic